Ironically working in my laboratory, the nuclear weapon is finally complete.
After it had been working good in my laboratory for hours.
I am literally tickled thinking about it.
Who's there?
Captain Literally.
Captain Irony.
Nuclear Ninja.
The Good and the Well Duo.
And Dangling Participle Dude.
Everything was wrong with that sentence.
So wait, who are you?
Dangling Participle Dude.
Everyone's heard of him, but no one actually knows what he does.
Whatever. You broke all the rules, so now you're gonna pay.
There was nothing ironic about the sentence you just used.
You just tacked the word ironically in front of it.
Irony taught!
You said good when you should have said well.
Good and well are different!
There, literally tickled.
Balance restored!
Bro, your participles were dangling all over the place.
Dangle shmangle.